well that's how I perceived the rock
crit elite and my job was to turn them
around but my job was also to see true
ecstatics like prints like John Michael
Jackson was not an ecstatic onstage
Michael Jackson was an incredible
astonishing performer who had studied
his craft from the age of 9 and so he
worked out every single move in advance
John you never knew from one night to
the next what prints or John Mellencamp
were gonna do in performance they didn't
know how well did you know Michael
Jackson I thought very very well and he
was the most remarkable person I've ever
met in my life
and when I tell people how remarkable
they don't believe me he was you know
you and I and Jamie are on a certain
level and we don't know we're on a
certain level because we figure these
are the range this is the range of
humanity if we go out and meet anybody
on the street or even anybody famous I
work with Buzz Aldrin these days what
we're gonna encounter is another person
pretty much like us sorry in Michael
Jackson's case he did not fit on this
normal plane at all he was on a plane
somewhere where you've never seen a
human being before so the first time I
met him we were at his brother Marlins
have pool house it's a little house with
just enough room for one big room on the
first floor and another big room on the
second floor with a little tiny
staircase between them and there's a
billiard table in the middle of the room
and there are arcade games which at that
point in particular 1983 were
unattainable no human could afford
arcade games unless you were Steve Wynn
and you were actually equipping in
arcade so we're in the middle we're in
this room and Michael and I are standing
next to each other so his elbow is that
his left elbow is it my right elbow his
left knee is at my right knee and we
have a meeting with the art director
from CBS I'm condensing the story
there's lots more but we're having a
meeting with the art director and she
walks in with five of the most gorgeous
portfolios you've ever seen in your life
and carved cherry wood hand-carved
leather and these are from guys I know
because I was I started in pop culture
in the art business and these were my
legendary competitors and and Michael
opens the first page of the first
portfolio and he gets a square inch into
it a postage stamp size piece into it
and he goes oh and his knees begin to
buckle and he gets another two square
inches into it just lifts the page a
little bit further
oh he lifts it an even further oh
Michael is seeing the infinite in the
things that even the artists didn't see
it with such infinity as Michael is
seeing it and by the time he gets to the
full page he's having a full scale
aesthetic orgasm I have never seen
anything like this in my life and
remember the first two rules of science
are the truth at any price including the
price of your life and look at things
run under right under your nose as if
you've never seen them before and then
proceed from there
Michael is seeing the infinite in the
tiniest of things and you've never seen
a human with this degree of awe Wonder
and surprise anywhere in your life and I
will never see another human like that
again in my lifetime
Michael was beyond belief utterly beyond
belief and his commitment to his
audience to his the people he called his
kids Oh God
I forgot to turn this off